hallo leute ich es wieder rehberg
marseille und willkommen zu einem neuen
video in diesem fantastischen video geht
es um das teehaus dosha und mittlerweile
ist dass sie das dritte video in dem ich
irgendwie doch mit einbeziehe
ich habe ein komplettes test video über
diesen teeladen gedreht und bei lauffen
und saufen war ich auch bei deutscher
und habe euch diesen laden vorgestellt
was soll ich sagen ich liebe diesen
teeladen und mittlerweile habe ich mein
absolutes life ball erreicht denn timo
wurde auch süchtig nach einem ganz
bestimmten t der früchtetee der tochter
früchtetee
als ich diesen themen im test-video
probiert habe fand ich ihn gar nicht so
gut also ich habe ihn 7 von 10 punkten
gegeben aber das lag daran dass ich die
grünen tee version genommen habe und
nicht die schwarze version irgendwann
haben uns dann bei diesen schwarztee mit
den früchten geholt und waren so hin und
weg es ist wirklich unser absolutes
lieblingsgetränk geworden wir müssen ihn
ziemlich oft trinken und einfach diese
sucht auch zu stellen
der geschmack ist schwer zu beschreiben
also man hat so einerseits diesen
besseren schwarztee und dann kommt immer
wieder diese süß sauren fruchtstücke in
deinen mund explodieren einfach dass du
dich fühlst wie bei fuß
und fast so ein halben kriegst doch der
größte nachteil am see ist einfach dass
er vier euro 50 pro becher kostet
natürlich müssen die leute in dem laden
auch was verdienen vielleicht ist der
preis auch total gerechtfertigt es ist
aber für so einen regelmäßigen konsum
ein bisschen zu teuer und deshalb
versuchen wir ihn heute so gut es geht
zu kopieren und wie startet man so eine
kunstfälschung natürlich in dem man in
den laden geht und sich noch machen so
ein becher greift und einen dritten kam
um die zutaten ganz genau unter die lupe
zu nehmen welche habe ich dann über ein
sieb ausgekippt um mal ganz genau
hinzuschauen was steckt da drin
auf der zutatenliste steht assam
schwarztee maracuja ananas apfel und
orange danach hat mich auf jeden fall
die farbe der stückchen irritiert denn
alle hatten die gleiche farbe ob es
jetzt ananas apfel oder maracuja war
also maracuja sind ja nur die schwarzen
kerner es könnte orangensaft sein es
könnte aber auch die passion fit sein
denn die hat auch eine sehr intensive
orange farbe kommen wir zu dem schwarz
täter soll eine leichte trübung hatte
was mich vermuten ließ dass der apfel
saft drin ist also so naturtrüber
apfelsaft oder orangensaft denn nach
einer zeit hat sich da oben so eine
schicht mit stückchen abgesetzt und das
muss auf jeden fall von irgendeiner
flüssigkeit kommen von dieser frucht
pampe weil sie natürlich da nicht so
trocken drin liegen und warum da orange
in der zutatenliste steht ist klar dafür
muss ich kein sherlock sein es ist eine
orangenscheibe dran aber vielleicht jahr
orangensaft man weiß es nicht daraufhin
folgt natürlich der nächste logische
schritt man kauft die zutaten ein die
auf der liste stehen passion fruit oder
maracuja was ihr jetzt am liebsten sagt
ich weiß nicht warum man immer beides
sagen kann und niemand stört sich daran
dass das ding einfach zwei namen hat
apple in dem fall habe ich mich für
granny smith äpfel entschieden denn sie
sind sehr knackig also haben einen guten
bis und haben eine schöne säure ich als
altländer rinn kann natürlich sehr viel
über äpfel sagen ich habe ein großes
wissen wollt ihr das alte land nicht
kennt das ist es da wachsen sehr viele
sehr viele äpfel und dann natürlich
ananas und orangen beim thema sich
tatsächlich ein bisschen länger durchs
regal schauen weil ich jetzt auch nicht
so der große die experte bin und mein
supermarkt hatte tatsächlich asam
schwarztee
lohse in seiner tüte oder in so einem
beutel und dann habe ich noch sehr
langsam gefunden als teebeutel was
natürlich ein bisschen einfacher ist das
macht man einfach in das heiße wasser
rein fertig aber es gelang es dann
wieder auch eine andere schwarz teesorte
und das ist dann so eine mischung und
wir wollen ja wirklich ein all-star
schwarztee
deswegen habe ich einfach mal beide
aufgekocht und wollte mal wissen wieso
der unterschied schmeckt kurzer weg zur
smt tiefs vom strauch der veritas amica
haben einen kräftigen mal ziegen
geschmack ich bin aber dafür das thema
jetzt mittlerweile wirklich mal seine
zeit bekommt und wir mehr tee als café
konsumieren wir wissen doch mittlerweile
das café einfach nicht gut für unseren
körper ist ab und zu mal bestimmen eine
tasse das schadet sich aber tee ist
gesünder starbucks du kannst einpacken
und deutscher wenn wir schon mal gerade
hier bei starbucks sind dann kommt meine
goldene karte in der ich endlich einfach
bei euch vorbei gehen kann und mit t
home und nun kommen wir zur zubereitung
beziehungsweise vorbereitung für unseren
tee wir fangen mit dem tee kochen an und
bei deutscher stehen so riesige tee kann
wo ich mich einfach nur so drunter legen
könnte aber man muss bei tee und dem
koffein auch aufpassen den sollte man
zum beispiel nicht mehr am nachmittag
trinken denn er wirkt über eine längere
zeit als kaffee kaffee hat so nach einer
halben stunde seine volle wirkung und
schwestern shop dann wieder so ab bei
schwarz dem was wirklich gut ist ist das
sehr hart über eine längere zeit braucht
um seine ganzen koffein doch wieder
irgendwie zu entfalten früher auch tein
genannt funny face an der seite deswegen
t am vormittag zum frühstück morgens um
wach zu werden und so eine tasse kaffee
zum kaffee und kuchen ist ja auch was
nettes aber nicht andersrum also picasso
uhr morgens machen aber wieder kein tier
am nachmittag schlafen ist sehr wichtig
leute wenn der tee dann drei minuten in
seinem wasserbad gezogen hat schnell
raus nehmen denn länger als drei bis
vier minuten sollte der tv wirklich
nicht im heißen wasser sein denn sonst
kann er ziemlich bitter werden was der
schmied so viel intensiver und dann geht
es an die früchte die maracuja
aufschneiden und alles rausholen was da
drin steht und natürlich auch ein
bisschen probieren und mehr
das ist viel zu sauer und die äpfel
schälen und klein schneiden und das
gleich auch mit der andern das natürlich
so dass sie durch einen strohhalm passen
am anfang hab ich ein bisschen groß
geschnitten und war dann irgendwann so a
klein schneiden aber nicht zu klein man
will ja auch noch aufs korn
es muss wir sind am besten großen
strohhalm so diese papier großen ströme
und guckt dann wird und jetzt wird es
wissenschaftlich denn wer weiß denn
schon wie viel von was da drin sein muss
aus dieser frucht pampel konnte ich
entdecken das halt so ja maracuja drin
war aber wie viel konnte ich auch nicht
so wirklich erkennen viele ananas stücke
ich glaube ein bisschen mehr anders als
abbild und dann habe ich das halt alles
so ein bisschen zusammen gemixt und
erstmal verrührt und gemerkt auch schade
kredit werbung noch nicht ganz eintreten
ich habe aber noch ein trick 17 und
deswegen habe ich noch eine orange
halbiert und enthaftet um dann den saft
da rein zu geben damit man halt so einen
schönen frucht mischung saft irgendwie
hat aber dann habe ich gemerkt dass der
auch nicht anfängt abzufärben und dann
dachte ich vielleicht braucht man für
diese geschichte auch geduld das fehlt
mir ja ganz oft dass ich für sachen
nicht genug geduld habe also habe ich es
zugedeckt und in den kühlschrank gemacht
und jetzt hat er die frucht pampe über
nacht zeigt sich so ein zu suppen und
ich gucke jetzt mal was daraus geworden
ist ich wollte mir noch nicht anschauen
ich vermute jetzt nicht dass die äpfel
wirklich orange geworden sind aber ich
hole mal ganz kurz
wie vermutet haben jetzt die äpfel nicht
wirklich die farbe angenommen von dieser
ganzen pampel vielleicht waren da ja
auch nie apfelstücke drin und habe ich
probiere es einfach mal so ein apfel
stück oh mein gott ist es die pumps war
sehr sauer aber ich glaube das ist es
warum gespalten auf teams reaktion wenn
der das ding ich liebte schluss bekommt
mein wohnzimmer
szenenwechsel hier wir haben jetzt
braucht pappe tees und nein auf jeden
fall erstmal eine orangenscheibe noch ab
was glaubst du wie wird das schmecken
ich hoffe genau gleich wieder so scharf
wie viel eis möchten sie halb
natürlich wird in meinem t shop erstmal
neue scheibe orange reingelegt sie
bereit für die frucht pump
ich krieg das schau mich wenn ich das so
ganz hoch in kippel bisschen schwächer
geworden
[Musik]
ich glaube das sind keine apfelstücke
darin als typische dem boden sie
wirklich nicht abdrängen aber schön
sieht's auch wenn du das jemanden zu
hause anbietet und sagst hier trinkt mal
selbst gemachte eis geht die dröhnt
durch durch der trend durch die
stückchen damit groß geschnitten ich
dachte es die klinischen endpunkt man
den anderen wenn man was machen die
anlass noch drumherum
also ist ein geiler fruchtiger eis dem
aber schon ähnliches schon sehr ähnlich
der brunch naja und dieses stück in
doral gemacht hat muss anna das ist
ananas das ist nur an der nacht das
gelbe kiste jemand anderes ultra süß
deswegen liegt diese krasse süße ab ich
will auf alle wahrscheinlich abfällt und
das würde total zusammen passen wir die
dinger sind hier so aussah als sei sie
aber ich merke schon mal geil und ich
will da gar nicht so drin sein weil der
schon da oben
aber du hast recht definitiv ananas wie
du schon gesagt hat da machen wir
vielleicht einfach wirklich naturtrüben
abgesagt ein bisschen rein wir haben
können wir noch mal ausprobieren ich
glaube die anderen reagieren muss
dahinter sondern zutatenliste ich weiß
noch nicht wo ich hoffe mal kurz im
harten einschnitten
dann auf zum supermarkt also haben wir
uns kurzerhand entschieden noch mal los
zu fahren und mehr ananas zu kaufen
zu hause muss ich dann alles wieder von
vorne machen ananas schneiden in kleine
stücke dass sie durch einen strohhalm
passen die passionsfrucht halbieren und
das innere raus haben und dieses mal
habe ich meine ganze konzentration
angewendet um die perfekte balance
zwischen ananas und passionsfrucht zu
finden ich hab so gemacht als ich
geguckt habe viele kerne sind vergleich
zu andern das drin und nicht abfällt
dann wurde natürlich noch einen tee
aufgegossen dieses mal habe ich nur den
schwarzen assam tee genommen der lose
nicht der mit zählung wir wollen ja hier
die eins zu eins kopie und jetzt habe
ich ein ziemlich cooles gefühl ich denke
mal alle guten dinge sind zwei ich hoffe
nicht drein denn noch einmal will ich
mache mir ist auch die passionsfrucht
ausgegangen also dieses mal muss es
jetzt klappt der ts abgekühlt ich habe
meine orangenscheiben vorbereitet ich
hier steht alles rallye wenn es jetzt
nicht klappt dann bin ich traurig
probiere einfach mal die fruchtbar nun
mal kurz um zu wissen womit die hier
arbeiten
das ist ist craig das ist das können mit
dem krieg eine orangenscheibe um ein
bisschen mehr orangengeschmack
reinzubringen pressen wir dann noch
besser sein so nicht zu viel und
natürlich steht auf der zutatenliste
apfel und den packen wir es auch rein in
form von naturtrüben apfelsaft ich mache
erst mal nur ein ganz kleines
schlösschen reinigt ich habe so angst
ist es zu verdanken kleiner schuss die
haben wir unsere pumpe und falls es
nicht süß genug wird habe ich hier noch
zuckersirup aber ich hoffe einfach dass
es jetzt klappt
und baby geht ihm baby keeper einfach
geblieben
es ist das krieg ich mal ein schuss
zucker rein weil es ist noch nicht ganz
süß das ist es wir haben wo mein gott
das ist so lecker spart euch wirklich
diese eistees aus den kartons macht euch
so eine kleine frucht ampel macht in
euch in schwarzem tee rein und dann habt
ihr den super gesunden eistee jetzt auch
mit weißem rohrzucker drin aber das kann
man wenigstens selber entscheiden wie
viel zucker man rein macht das ist ein
großer vorteil weil ich sie gerade nicht
da war um es selber zu probieren mache
ich eben noch mal seinen ganz eigenen
probieren ja man gerade der originale
geschmack nah dran
baki juni empfehle ich euch den selber
zu machen absolut ich glaube das ist
mein sommergetränk 2021 selbstgemachte
eistee mit ein bisschen frucht pampe
drin kann man ja auch rein machen was
man will und falls es hier das drt haus
sieht leute ich werde immer noch zu euch
in den laden kommen aber manchmal muss
ich mir auch selber machen das ist wie
im leben manchmal muss man es sich
einfach selber machen so und ich hoffe
euch als gefallen das video und hier
findet ihr meine anderen kanäle und ein
letztes video und ich wünsche euch viel
spaß beim nachmachen und bis bald